hey guys dr. Burke here in this short
video we're gonna talk about cataracts
first of all what is a cataract
basically a clouded lens your lens
starts becoming cloudy to the point
where you can't see anymore and then
they have to do surgery so this happens
in the normal aging process a lot of
stress side effect from prednisone
side-effect from having too much insulin
diabetics pre-diabetics insulin
resistance all these things are related
to insulin in general okay so there's
two great remedies that you can get I'll
put some links down below I don't
recommend any brands but I'll just kind
of tell you the form that you need
because you need a special type of fat
soluble vitamin b1 normally b1 comes in
a water-soluble but being fat soluble it
penetrates the cell membrane to get deep
into the eye to help repair cataracts
this is really really good also for
peripheral neuropathies anything related
to nerve issues but you know a diabetic
usually kind of goes blind eventually
because of the depletion of the what
glucose does to the depletion of b1 so
putting that back in can really help
your vision and so you have to get into
fat soluble form the next one is NAC
drops an acetyl carnosine this is
another great remedy that you can take
and drop so you can get it anywhere I'll
put a link down below and you can start
to use that to repair the lens of the
eye but of course don't forget to get
your diet squared away to fix this and
this right here okay and I created
videos on that as well I'll put some
links down below alright go ahead and
put your comments down below